accueilli par une marée humaine d'au
moins 30 000 personnes vêtues de rouge
couleurs du Parti travailliste l'icône
de la gauche brésilienne s'est rendu au
palais du Planalto pour sa cérémonie
d'investiture sous haute sécurité à bord
de la traditionnelle Rolls-Royce
décapotable
une minute de silence a été tenue en
hommage à la légende poli et à l'ancien
pape Benoît XVI les vestitures de Luis
Inacio Lula da Silva
qui promet entre autres d'atteindre 0
déforestation en Amazonie et zéro
émission de gaz effets de serre
partisans au Congrès il en demeure
autrement du côté des militants du
président des fées jaillir bossunaru qui
a d'ailleurs quitté le Brésil pour la
Floride où il en a profité pour
rencontrer quelques admirateurs
après demander à la tête du Brésil de
2003 à 2010 et après un séjour en prison
c'est un retour exceptionnel de Lula en
politique aux yeux de bien des analyses
je pense que le troisième mandat de loi
va être le plus difficile parce que il
va prendre le pouvoir d'un pays qui n'a
quasiment pas
grandi son économie depuis 10 ans
sera de s'attaquer à la pauvreté qui
aurait grimpé ces dernières années
précis cette travailleuse sociale de Sao
Paulo
cette dame qui tient dans ses bras son
bébé de trois mois raconte avoir vécu
avec lui dans la rue
cet autre femme constate que beaucoup
vivent encore sans accès à l'eau ni à
l'électricité
dans tous les cas Lula qui vient de
recevoir l'écharpe présidentielle d'y
avoir la volonté de reconstruire le pays
avec les Brésiliens ici Gabriel proud
Radio-Canada Montréal